Hey, everyone what's up.
It's Rob Dodson.
Today on Polycasts,
I'm going to take
a look at building icon sets
with the new iron iconset
elements.
Also going to show you a
very useful performance tip,
so be sure to stick
around for that.
Now, without further
ado, let's get hacking.
OK, so in this episode,
we're going back in time.
We're updating the old
episode on core-iconset-svg,
and now we're going to be
using the new iron-iconset-svg
element.
So looking at our code
from the last episode,
the changes are going
to be pretty minimal.
So any place where you
see core-iconset-svg,
we would just replace that with
iron-iconset-svg including down
in the tag name here.
And in the old episode,
and with the old element,
you would use an ID to
reference your icon set.
That has been updated.
So now in the 1.0
version, you use name
to reference your icon
set that you're creating.
And iconSize, that has just
been simplified to size.
So over here, you
can see in my editor,
I've got the icon
set that I created
in the original episode.
It looks pretty much the same.
We've got the
iron-iconset element
with our SVG inside of it.
And we've still got our
fancy-circles icon here.
Note that the icon itself
still uses an ID, while you
use a name for the icon set.
Now, over here in my
project, again this
looks very similar
to the old episode.
I've updated the polyfills
to webcomponents-lite.js.
I'm using iron-icons
now and av-icons
instead of the old core icons.
I'm using a paper-icon-button.
And then lastly here I'm
importing my icon set
that I've created.
And then down here, the
syntax to use an icon
is still the same.
You prefix it with
your icon set name
with a colon and then
the name of your icon.
And here I'm using an AV
icon from a different set.
So you see I use its name.
And lastly, for icons coming
out of the default set,
you can just use
their regular name.
You don't have to
prefix anything that
comes from the iron-icons set.
So if I go to my
browser and I run this,
everything is going to
look and work exactly
like it did in the old
episode, which is really great.
But I want to show you
this very, very important
performance trick because it
could shave off maybe hundreds
of kilobytes from your site.
So what I'm going to do
is pop open the dev tools,
and I'm going to filter
it to just look for files
with the name icons in it.
And when I refresh the
page, what you'll see here,
I've got the
iron-icons that loaded,
av-icons that loaded,
and I've got the custom-icons
set that loaded as well.
Now, check out the file
size for these icon sets.
You can see that iron-icons
is like 59 KB, which
is pretty big, the av-icons is
15 KB, and then my icon set,
that one little icon that I
created was 2.2 kilobytes.
So I'm only using like one
icon from each set, which
means I'm incurring
like what, about 70
KB of additional weight
for just two icons,
which is pretty wasteful.
And you could imagine if
you were pulling icons
from two, three, four
additional icon sets,
this would really
start to add up.
So what I want to do
is take these two icons
and just dump them into my
custom-icons set to really cut
down on the overhead.
So to do that, I'm going
to go back into my project.
And I'm going to just open
up the av-icons set to start.
I'm going to find the play
arrow that's inside of here.
And again, it's just
one big SVG file,
so I just find that
element and I drop it
into my custom-icons set right
after that fancy-circles icon.
Go to the iron-icons set,
and I find that android icon.
Again, just sort
of copy and paste
this right out of
the original icon
set into my smaller,
more refined set.
And now I've got my
custom icon set going.
I can hop open into
my original project
and get rid of the AV icons
and get rid of the iron
icons because I don't
need the whole set.
I'm just going to load the
iron icon element, right?
So I can actually use the icons.
And I'm going to go down, and
I'm going to update the name.
So any place where
it said AV icons,
I'll change it to custom icons.
Where it said android, I'll
change that custom icons.
And now when I go back to my
project and I refresh the page,
you'll see that all my
icons continue to load,
but check out the file size.
Now it's just 8K
down from around,
you know, what was that?
Like 70K.
So this is a really, really,
really important trick
for you to learn.
It's wonderful to develop
with these icon sets.
I really enjoy it.
It makes it very convenient.
But when it's time
to go to production,
you've got to make
sure that you're
trimming these things down.
You don't have excess
icons that you're
loading that are just going
to slow down the user's
initial load experience.
So hope this tip helps
you build slightly more
performant applications.
So that about covers it.
You now know how to work with
1.0 iron iconset SVG elements,
and your site
should be a smaller
thanks to that little
trick that I showed you.
That's it for this week, folks.
Be sure to click that
little subscribe button.
If you have questions, leave
them down the comments below.
As always, thanks you
so much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]